so i always thought like
you know safe sex was the way to go
you know condoms and condoms only but
i'm finding out the streets are wild
apparently okay and apparently men
have types of girls i'm trying to keep
it youtube friendly
that they they they rap it for
and types of girls that they don't
so i want to hear it from the guys
can go for it is
don't i told them the topic beforehand
so don't go first i know we live now
um
yes it's a thing it's very much a thing
can we see how many people
that time they're like what do you like
how do you want how do you want me to
break this down like what's like the
rationale yeah yeah so like what okay so
you meet a girl right
y'all are you're vibing it's going well
okay sorry carry on sir okay okay
and she she's down to like you know yeah
do do the d gonna do the damn thing
um what goes through your head when
you're like
condom or no condom
uh is it is it what she says or do you
do you differentiate
honestly
depends on a few things
uh
some of it first of all it's like how
much of this
wasn't just a process
but uh
even before that
i think some of it is also like
you know
trying to get a quick judge
of this person's character like
i feel like sometimes like
i'm sure it's the same for women like
you can kind of tell
what kind of person you're dealing with
like is this person
chill like are they kind of like are
they always in the mix
are they kind of
are they more laid back
um
sometimes some red flags stand out to
you like while you're talking to the
person or just kind of the vibes that
give off it's kind of like some unspoken
stuff
like what red flags
i want to see i want to see if i like
i want to see which ones i have i'm
excited there's no like exact form okay
i'm just gonna say for me like i'm not
one of those people like
um
in terms of like it's rare for me like
to have like a one night stand type of
thing it's only happened a few times
um
usually in these scenarios like
if we're about to have sex like
i've been evaluating you for a little
bit you know what i'm saying like
we've mingled at some occasion or like
i've seen you at other functions or
whatever and just seeing how you act
around other dudes
um
and
you know maybe like if i've already
heard about you
that's a red flag yeah like no no you
already heard like are you talking to a
girl like you're already hearing from
your brothers like hey man like just you
know be careful like
i'm gonna say
the first red flag you already the
streets will talk like
if you already hear stuff from your bros
hey hey but
yeah like
it that's that's probably the first
um
second is just kind of like
when you're when you're talking to the
person you know spitting game or
whatever
how quickly they are to like
you know
be down you know what i'm saying like
remember remember remember what we're
talking about what we were talking about
before when we finished working out yeah
but i was like like
this will tell you some [ __ ] just to
just to feed it to you so you you don't
you don't go there for me so like you
gotta
find out if you're like because
like guys you know how guys like we
already spoke about you know how guys
are like don't just say some [ __ ] just
to
so you don't go there like no more
they'll try to protect you uh yeah there
are ones that will try to protect you
but then there's guys that do just be
like hey
nah don't go there but really you're
naturally like in his head he's like i
want to go there but you don't like you
you ain't going there before me do you
think some guys like sabotage each other
most
i think most yeah i think bush also
known as youtube [ __ ] blocking yes yes
yes um
it's very real
uh but it's like it's one of those
things like how do you prove it you know
well because it always comes down to
like the he said she said and i think
men and women both have like incentive
to lie
you know
hustle
like i mean men it looks better if they
hook up with more girls
like other guys but i agree with that
yeah so like like some guy some guys
like will
will lie about that sort of stuff but
then on the other side like the girls
will lie too when you say when you say
lie like are they lying about actually
the action they did do like lying about
their body count no like lying and say
they hooked up with a girl who they
didn't oh yeah i knew yeah yeah
just to like say that they did yeah
because like i remember when i was 18 i
was uh i was a freshman in college i was
a virgin so i didn't have sex with
anybody
and like i'd find out like someone was
saying that they slept with me and i was
like well i haven't i've never had sex
before so i don't know
like when we would have but
i don't know sometimes guys will say
stuff like that no they definitely will
and it's funny how like you see the
parallels like usually with guys
they'll lie about
how many people they had sex with like
they'll gas the number
and then on the opposite side
i found with girls they'll try to
minimize the numbers yeah yeah yeah
but they're doing it to impress other
guys you know guys girls are doing it to
impress other girls as well and guys
though or i don't know
i think girls are a little more honest
with each other than like i think
they're wider girls are a lot of guys
i think girls like to girls bro like
look like how do i speak like
i think girls are slamming like i think
girls lie to other girls
so
[Music]
even their home no like what they got to
like not that not their girls bro but
like
i've see i cool obviously cool girls
yeah girls can meet each other right
in like let's say a party and then all
of a sudden they they might they might
touch the girl's ass and be like oh girl
you gotta you got a nice size
and then all of a sudden they're best
friends like how the [ __ ] does that work
and the reason why i'm saying that is
because it's like
you don't know this girl
so that this girl that has no loyalty to
you she don't she ain't good she ain't
gonna tell you ain't gonna tell you [ __ ]
she ain't gonna tell you true people
sure oh you [ __ ] that's true i'm saying
it's like i don't know girls are too
quick to be friends
like we ain't quick to be friends like
we like because i feel like when guys
talk it's just like we actually have to
talk does that make sense but i feel
like guys like
girls will be friends and they'll tell
each other stuff like guys will be best
friends and like say like nothing to
each other
or is that a misconception
maybe i don't know me my friends don't
know me my best friend we don't do that
in terms of like
when you say tell each other stuff like
people they're dealing with like on the
side like
it depends on your friend like you know
your friends you know friends who can
keep a secret and you know friends who
run their mouth
like you love them but you know they're
gonna talk like yeah
um yeah but that is true what you said
like bro i feel like with guys you gotta
meet you gotta run into a guy like bump
shows with him like at least eight times
before sometimes before you even have a
conversation bro like do you remember
when but those are the best friendships
you know what i'm you know what i'm
saying remember when we had to come like
we've been seeing each other right yeah
and just remember when we spoke i was
like bro like we we actually had a
genuine conversation you know you
understand that we had a genuine
conversation and we we spoke about
things we both saw that we didn't like
and did like you know what i'm saying
but we didn't we didn't see each other
instantly and like
oh what's good that we didn't do that
we had to we had one training session
had a couple training sessions
maybe we had even had a game
and
after the game we still didn't talk we
had them practice yeah yeah and even
practice we still talk like that and
then those one day we just like i just
came up to you and i was like hey bro
that's like we started speaking because
and that it was it was it wasn't like it
wasn't forced it just happened you
understand that it was just a normal
conversation
i don't think that [ __ ] happens with
girls
don't get twisted i do believe that does
happen with certain girls
but but by the majority like yeah the
majority i don't think that happens
up anyway